deux chiens pull a alors tout d'un seul
coup alors ça prend un temps pour se
réhabituer à cette perte l'a7 une perte
c'est prouvé même que tu es plus proche
à ton chien que certains noms de la
famille c'est tout voilà pour les
propriétaires d'animaux
c'est assez clair va peut-être une
journée au temps de travail
mais dans les faits l'employeur n'est
tenu à rien l'employé peut demander un
congé personnel s'il en a un employé qui
n'a pas droit de tels congés personnels
à ce moment là doit entrer au travail ou
encore appelé l'employeur pour lui
demander s'il peut prendre un congé sans
solde étant donné ce qui vient de se
produire
il ya quand même deux millions de chats
1 millions de chiens au québec et chaque
année 200 à 300 mines qui se font état
nasier et certains choisissent de les
enterrer dans des cimetières comme celui
ci mais la plupart du temps c'est dans
un cadre moins champêtre que l'on fait
ses adieux chez le vétérinaire
mais le temps n'est pas encore venu pour
pompon qui n'a qu'une petite boule à
l'oreille ces médecins sont bien placés
pour voir la détresse que provoque la
perte d'un animal sait quel genre si
l'animal devient véritable de installe
donc la personne
un attachement très très intense avec
son animal on peut comprendre qu'il ya
eu comme un choc post traumatique
lorsqu'un animal des soeurs dont ça se
peut qu'on soit au fonctionnel mais de
là à prétendre un congé payé en bonne et
due forme
parce que si t'es pas pour être
fonctionnel au travail mais je pense que
les contribuables devraient payer pour
ça qu'on pourrait suggérer serait
peut-être caniza points donnent des
congés familiaux
du côté du ministère du travail pas
question de changer les normes qui
viennent tout juste d'être revu
ça restera donc du cas par cas ici
mathieu prost radio canada montréal